welcome to conan o'brien needs a friend
uh i just
spit
some gum out of my mouth how many sticks
how many i think i put in three pieces
uh sona you've observed over the years
that
i'm incapable of having
just one stick of gum it is
but it's not even like uh it's you have
the pack
in your hand you take it you wrap up
wrap it you shove it in your mouth then
you unwrap another one you shove it in
your mouth then you unwrap another one
you shove it and it's like there's like
five or six pieces in there sometimes
and you chew it for like
five minutes and then you just spit it
out
it's [ __ ] weird
wow well i thought you were going to say
this was kind of endearing or this
little trade conan has but i you this
went it got bad i didn't mean to say it
is it is like when you were chewing
right now there is it's nice that i know
that you have so many
sticks in your mouth that is nice
there's something compulsive i i mean i
have a compulsive uh nature in some ways
and gum brings it out if there's
you know 20 pieces of gum in a pack
i want to get through them it feels to
me like a task like i've got to get
through these pieces of gum if it's the
little kind of small rectangles like the
tridents
i'll get like four of those in my mouth
and uh be chewing them and i feel like
i've got to get this done and then i've
got to get on to the next ones
i kind of understand do you understand
what i'm talking about i'm not happy
about that and you know what i think i i
don't smoke never smoked
but in movies i'm always fascinated when
people smoke because it speaks to me and
i think if i did smoke i'd be one of
those guys that smoked four packs a day
i would just be i'd be lighting one
cigarette getting through it and keeping
my eye on the next cigarette that's what
i'd be doing and and uh it would be it's
comp it's a compulsion you know what if
it's gum it's okay i don't see anything
wrong with it it's just sometimes you do
things with a way of showing that you're
like almost punishing yourself well no i
mean this is the way i brush my teeth
too yeah it's working
you're really hard on yourself when i
brush my teeth i just go through
toothbrushes really quickly because they
practically catch fire from the friction
of me brushing my own teeth which is why
i switched to one of those electric
toothbrushes because
you can't be as crazy but when i'm um
and it's the same way i mean i saw this
i grew up my father's the same way he
washes his hands
uh like he's um murdering his enemy
his lifelong enemy he washes his hands
and he's squeezing and if you could slip
a piece of coal in between his hands
while he's washing them he'd crush it
into a diamond like superman you do that
sometimes when you laugh really hard you
sit back of course yeah i'm compressing
and i used to think what is that people
would say are you nervous or something
and i go no it's extremes if i'm
extremely happy sometimes yeah or
pleased i squeeze my hands together like
i'm i don't know i don't know what it is
this is making me
sad for myself no don't be sad it's not
like you you could be using it in very
negative ways and you're not just
because you brush your teeth too hard or
you chew a lot of gum it could be a lot
have you seen me wash my face when i
used to take the makeup off
i've seen you put makeup on like if you
had if we were on the road or something
and you had to put some makeup on just
to just to like even out your face
you were in it it's almost like i want
to get this done so i could go on to the
next you know what it is it's all get
this done so i can get to the grave oh
there it is it really is
all this attitude of i've got to just
get this done
yay let's get this birthday party over
with so i can get to my grave
there's a grave waiting for me and i got
to get to it
and so yes there's a there's an angry
haste and i've tried so hard i've tried
meditation i've tried all these things
and
you know what's what is this meditation
i've got to get going let's go let's go
if you chew just one piece of gum what
what happens why can't you just chew one
take a tear one in half and just chew a
half a piece okay this is i'm gonna just
get the this is a trident original
flavor i don't know what that means oh
with gravy um
i love how it just says it's original
flavor trident 14 sticks sugar-free gum
with xylitol
oh i don't know how they can just say
that and i'm i'm okay with it yeah that
could be a terrible chemical it could be
putting it forward like it's a good
thing yeah it could be now
we know no no it's trident and
they don't
do ads with us or anything but i do know
and they got it for free after i've
mocked xylitol no it's a good gum and
it's a gum that i rely on
uh
okay so what do you want to do this is a
very small take a half this feels like
it's about an inch
yeah right that's i'd say that's two
it's a standard size
not a long piece you think this is two
inches that's it then i'm in good shape
oh man come on
that's an inch and three quarters by
half an inch or 5 8.
okay these are we'll be back with more
boring bets in a minute
you know what i bet you that peanut
weighs less than a gram
okay we'll be back hey we all have our
compulsions all right so i'm taking i
just broke this trident piece in half
yeah um i'm gonna try and just put that
in
all right
oh you're but you're chewing too close
you're chewing on that misophonia thing
that i can't take people cheating yeah
it's too close my daughter has that and
can't stand anyone chewing or eating
anything either
why did i ask
too much crunch but i'm okay with
everything else it's the it's not enough
yeah that's it it's just not
i won't i don't want to bother people
who are listening but i'm going to uh s
cease there'll be a cessation of all
chewing
a cessation of all macular activities
yeah
yes you really saved this podcast from
being boring
from the me guessing the width of the
gum
i snatched it from the jaws of defeat
okay hold on
yeah it's not enough yeah it's just not
enough yeah if that's then i would feel
the same way i
stopped the other day to get gas
man those prices are crazy but don't get
me started
yeah so much money electric car
that's that was insane to me
he just filled up the bag i filled the
whole back seat with gasoline
i forgot that i had an electric car you
don't smoke yeah
it was such a it's muscle memory i just
i was in my electric car and i pulled in
i was on my way back from uh you know
santa barbara and i i filled the back
seat with unleaded gasoline it cost
seven thousand dollars
it was all sloshing through holes in the
bottom of the car oh man that's
dangerous tries to charge his gas tank
no i stopped i was
driving yeah pickup truck that's right
i'm a guy and i um
yeah all my humble figurines were in the
back
and uh i but i i went in and i got those
you know they they sell gum that comes
in got sugar with gum that comes in
those canisters like a bucket like a
tumbler like a bucket like a tiny little
connection i was
i can't tell you how many pieces i put
in my mouth at one time you pour it in i
would that's what i did and it was nuts
i mean even i left my own body and
looked at myself and said what the what
are you doing yeah i got so much and i'm
so my whole mouth is just filled with
gum
and you like the berry flavors don't you
like
i like to try anything do you miss the
big gum of the 80s like hubba bubba oh
my god
bubblicious i love yeah hubba bubba
bubblicious uh those were fantastic but
again
they can't make a gum that's too big
that's that would be too big for me i
just like if they came out with a gum
called you know the big whopper
you know or what about big league chew
the face filler
brick-a-gum
yeah then i might be okay but did you
ever do everything
with the pouch i like that yeah i like
that a lot but
then i'm a heroin addict and i'm just in
a heroin den it's too much i could fit
but you're on methadone right now and
you're not getting any better no it's
okay you need to stop being so hard on
yourself if you want a lot of sticks of
gum just eat a lot of sticks of gum you
brought this up he wasn't being hard
you're right i brought it up and i said
it was [ __ ] weird didn't i yeah i did
i did i'm sorry there's a lot of things
about me that are maybe a little off or
strange but this podcast is maybe a way
to get them in the open yeah and maybe
lead to recovery
i do think when i when i see you doing
these things and also when i eat
yo like the way i eat you can tell i
grew up in a large family yeah i think
that a lot of this stuff though you're
like let me get through this so i could
get on to the thing i have to not the
grave but like the thing i have to do
because you're a very high functioning
person
not the grave hospital yeah you are just
very high functioning you have a lot of
things on your mind and those are the
things you'd rather be doing than things
like brushing your teeth i want to be in
the moment i very much want to be in the
moment i don't want to be like this
anymore i'd like to change you know what
i think you are in the moment when
you're performing or doing something yes
yeah no i am that's this is my happy
place
and um when i'm with
uh
family relatives wife kids
uh an endless torment okay let's get
started
that's a shout out to all my people
right there i love you